alors pour rendre hommage à tous les
sports quel qu'il soit on va faire un
toc toc toc spécial sport et vous allez
découvrir l'équipe du jour attention
c'est parti
premier toc toc toc qui est là c'est
foot foot qui fout ta cagoule fous ta
cagoule un peu dans l'air tu vas jouer
un peu dans l'herbe mais en tout cas et
sans rigoler tu sais quoi sait on dirait
quoi toi on dirait vraiment un joueur de
foot qui a pris sa retraite depuis qu'un
bourgeois
il reste un truc et on sent qu'il a vu
et a le commentateur qui fait et il n'y
a quand même pas encore pas beau
brillant il a quand même touché bon même
si au niveau de la course c'est pas
terrible avait elle encore à petites
touches et y aller mais ce avec raymond
a failli être professionnel de foot
ouais ça va c'est à ça non sérieux c'est
vrai que les ligaments croisés ne fait
pas une vanne j'avais moi ce qui m'a
assez pourquoi j'ai pas réussi c'est le
talon il m'a manqué quel talent peut
nous faire quelques jours non c'est fini
ça veut dire non non c'est à toi avec
ton physique il tombe physique et je
n'avais jamais vu encore vraiment
puisque je pense que à sexy dans le
dictionnaire iata en plus j'aimerais
avoir ouvert on voit qu'à quelques temps
les mecs taddart si si il a failli être
professionnel voilà maintenant et adil
rami va être très content que tu es
buisson allez c'est parti 2e toc toc toc
on y va toc toc toc qui est là judo judo
qui ôte judo cas bien sûr attaque
atteint dja dja djedje odiah cébazat
weppes a piqué pas ça tu veux me pécho
c'est presque ça chez moi
oui vous et pourquoi je ne sais pas je
vous la lumière on m'a mis une jolie 2
et régis goudot vous êtes ridicule je
sais j'avais déjà fait du judo
non non jamais mais en tout cas ça ça
doit il faire bien fondé de cette année
vous vous êtes où oui là bas l'instant
vous installer à laisser partir au
château flacco débat pour l'intéressé
qui est là ce qui fait après mon retour
je ressens évoqué jacques attali m'a dit
tu fais un très très beau au togo ce
seuil très bas autour laisser ce qui est
ce qu'il ya en plus un belge il était
tôt ce qui fait chaud mais ça va je suis
content on enfants il en est où pascale
breuil à l'enfant qui arrive un l'enfant
est à presque sept mois sept mois c'est
dire que pour la rentrée normalement
être à des jumeaux peut-être déjà l'on
fait on serait quand même pas bon le
médecin c'est la plus mauvaise le net il
n'a pas vu le deuxième derrière un nom
il y en a qu à bien l'action
allez c'est parti pour ce toponyme à
dakhla qui est là c'est hand en qui en
tout cas on voit les sportifs il ya
quelque chose on va vraiment au cas des
sportives donné à les hématies de kaka
qui est là c'est un donkey on dis moi
oui
[Musique]
[Rires]
oula c'est l'attaqué mais cette
agression ça c'est ma télé québec vous
êtes magnifique conduite au fromage mais
nan mais sérieux mais ça ça me va perdre
bien ça rigolait bravo pena immense
merci à vous pour l'instant cela n'offre
attendez vous le voyez de vous-même
soyaux phrase qui ressort à et l'inde
haryana paca alors franchement pour
l'instant pour moi y'en a pas un cas à
part peut-être raymond parce que
vraiment c'est vrai qu'il est élégant
mais sinon non
sinon allez c'est parti prochain toc toc
toc toc toc toc qui est là c'est pas
d'elles podolski
c'est bon vous avez déjà vu une meuf qui
va qu'il va jouer au paddock et sexy bon
bah ouais vous foutez de la gueule des
jolie et sexy c'est joli séminaire est
jolie elle adore quand vous êtes dans le
public pareil d'accord bas très bas très
bas mais teboul a pour l'instant c'est
vraiment un naufrage
on est sûr de la tristesse vraiment
absolue voilà mais quoi on peut le
démontrer
[Rires]
allez c'est parti le prochain qui est là
jean-michel maintenant cinq ans pour le
faire olala à la doc qui est là mélo qui
vélo qui est ce que tu m'entends bello
mais lol lol au complet mais lolo est ce
que je serai là jonathan dubas et vous
voilà dans son virage
c'est lui qui gagne je veux jean-michel
je vous adore mais vous êtes encore plus
triste que les autres mais franchement
il faudrait santé j'ai pas j'ai sorti
avant de rentrer je me dis jamais tu as
loupé une dizaine book mais là c'est
vrai que là on atteint des ag dans
naufrage on atteint nouveau défi cette
année on dirait bon vide les bronzés ou
merci en tout cas à jean michel vous
vous donnez un fond c'est l'essentiel
c'est faux mais sinon ça fait surtout
toc toc c'est viril
c'est en mer du don et au refaite au toc
toc toc toc toc thomas n'ont pas les i
toc toc toc
sa sainteté comment vous le faites vous
battre stoke toc toc c'est pas mal oui
c'est différent oui c'est ça ma barrows
fait le bateau toc toc tsubasa olive à
l'est pas takacs
mais dans le fait que faites vous faites
le vous même attaque il ya beaucoup plus
avenant non mais c'est vrai qu'on fait
le bas jusque là où je mangeais ariane
sonnerie donc alors toc toc toc
et puis hélas c'est basketball basterds
fait que ça marche pas sinon ça aurait
pu aller qui est là
la quéquette basket qui comme ça c'est
bon c'est bon départ ils s'engueulaient
mais la ballon de basket ils n'ont pas
pu gonfler d'un bagage garde s'est passé
c'est pas parce que vous saviez qui
rebondissait pas vous fait de la muscu
vous voulez qu'on fasse un jeu à quoi
voir celui qui fait bondir le ballon
basket le plus haut à les agents bien
les salaires en faisant ça voilà
d'accord qu'est ce qu'on gagne on gagne
propres ailes on gagne 1,1 à léogâne
petit gars c'est bien d'avoir ce touché
un dîner on a vu se prendre dans les
bras un dîner à l'itie un dîner mais non
mais non il faut faire comme ça mais je
compose je remercie je regarde si ça va
toucher ou pas à la sauce manouche et
genre cerner tout prix
mais non mais bien tapé juste mais je
l'étais le terrain et non pas pardon
mais mes potes la roue tourne et non
comme ça pour vous la claque les mecs
qui sont basques et là ils font ça pour
ça allez vas-y vas-y emmerdes nul alors
pas mal pas mal
cyril vat explosé je prendrais c'est
sûrement ça eh ben non c'est chez lui
c'est plutôt s'évalue non mais non sans
rire et gagnent en équipe et sa tchatche
marek
il faut mettre en file donc on va
organiser sa non gt2 vorace et regagné
leurs interactions avec le lac leman on
cuit dur cela je met ma main al-anbari
chef marc vazy mais ne me reconnais j'ai
gagné son couple en cédant dans ce style
c'est excessif à temps si court sur il
perd il a pris les noms mais il a pris
très bel ombre
c'est autant des parodies la gagner non
non mais un petit glace on sera pas mal
pourquoi pas parce que s'ils ont cédé
sais pas vous mais en fait avec élan que
je ne serais pas venu pour rien dans son
porter attention à vous c'était le
meilleur
je me suis empressé à cyril